make of thyselves
that which he desire
be as a lord
be as a god
but should he fail to become ought at
all you will be forsaken
amounting only to sacrifices
[Music]
in order to talk about the tarnished we
need to understand the history behind
the lands between and what has brought
us to this point
the lands between are watched over by
the greater will who is a being of great
power responsible for the creation of
the elden ring and the golden order of
the earth tree
the elden ring was housed within the
earth tree which would in turn bless the
land and its inhabitants with the grace
of the elden ring bringing an incredible
level of order to the land
the greater will also selected an
individual by the name of marika to rule
the lands between
she would be the guardian and keeper of
the elden ring
marika would go on to find a consort
godfrey who would become the first elden
lord and they would rule the lands
between together having several children
marika would eventually go on to
purposely alter the elden ring by
removing the rune of destined death
making everybody under the grace of the
elden ring immortal
but the elden ring and the earth tree
seemed to reject some of them
marking them as tarnished
they had been deemed as unworthy in some
way
these inhabitants still couldn't die but
they had been sent into exile banished
from the land
godfrey was a mortal hero of legendary
status
he was the chosen consort and first
husband of queen america
as queen mariko was the goddess the
children she had with godfrey possessed
demigod status
america had godfrey leader conquest
attacking neighbouring kingdoms in an
effort to expand the influence of the
greater will
one of these wars was waged against the
fire giants
the storm lord led the giants in the
conflict and when the time came godfrey
would engage in single combat that would
eventually lead to the demise of the
storm lord
but it is said after defeating his
greatest challenger in battle godfrey's
warrior spirit left him along with his
grace
the light surrounding his body and the
energy imbued by the earth tree fled
godfrey's spirit
leaving him broken
having been rejected by the earth tree
america had little choice but to exile
godfrey from the lands between making
him the first tarnished
since then a number of others who have
been affected in the same way were also
banished from the lands
[Music]
eventually an event that would be known
as the shattering would change the face
of the lands between forever
this was on the night of the black
knives where a claim of mysterious
assassins invaded killing many including
america's eldest born
during the fighting the elden ring was
somehow damaged and shattered fragments
of the rings splinted into great ruins
and spread across the lands between
starting a conflict between america's
demigod children to determine who would
be america's successor
the end result of the war was a
stalemate between numerous factions
many demigods now have great ruins
scavenged from the damaged elden ring
but none have properly risen to power to
either replace america or become the new
elden lord
this pointless middle ground caused the
elden ring's blessing to partially fade
from the lands between
centuries have passed
tarnished are now being called back to
the lands between by the earth tree in
an attempt to break the stalemate
most tarnish can only faintly perceive
the grace and lose sight of it
altogether after arriving in the lands
between
this leaves them directionless and
without hope
some of these tarnished go on to fall
prey to a form of corruption called cis
blood
becoming frenzied killers who
obsessively hunt their fellow tarnished
other tarnished who prove themselves are
given passage to the round table hold a
hidden place of refuge where violence
between tarnished is forbidden
and then there is a very small amount of
tarnished who were chosen to be
sponsored by a finger maiden a human
representative of the two fingers
granting them the power to convert ruins
to strength
setting them on the path to becoming the
new elden lord by seizing the great
runes from the demigods and restoring
the elden ring
so to answer the question
all of the tarnished in the lands
between originally became exiled because
they'd fallen from grace in one way or
another
they are individuals who no longer have
the life force of the earth tree running
through them
being labeled as tarnished is a title
that brings great shame
however individual tarnished have now
been given the opportunity to grow in
strength and power by collecting the
great runes repairing the elden ring and
becoming the new elden lord
changing this damaged realm to reflect
the ideals and desires of whatever side
they are working with
this was my first installment for this
game so i wanted to keep it relatively
simple and straightforward
i have purposely been quite ambiguous
with a lot of what i've said in order to
stick to the question at hand but also
to keep the spoilers to a minimum i'll
certainly be expanding on some of what
i've talked about here later on
i'm somewhat testing the waters here
with this video this is a genre i really
haven't covered before and i'm not
really sure of what interests my
followers will have with this however as
far as the game goes i'm completely
hooked so regardless of the outcome i
think this will be my next obsession for
a little while
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]